tensions are high in the Middle East
this morning where Israel has sent
additional troops to the West Bank
following Friday's Day of Rage at least
six people were killed in clashes
centered around increased security
measures at a site sacred to Jews and
Muslims in Jerusalem Jane Ferguson has
more from our London bureau jenga
morning good morning after a day of
deadly violence Israeli forces patrolled
a tense West Bank this morning a family
of Jewish settlers were killed Friday
night by a Palestinian teenager the
attacker snuck into their home and
stabbed to death a woman and two men
before being shot by a neighbor their
murders an apparent revenge for the
killing of three Palestinian protesters
during clashes with Israeli security
forces earlier that day thousands of
Muslim worshippers prayed in the street
rather than enter mosques in Jerusalem
on Friday they were protesting against
metal detectors placed at the gates of
the al-aqsa mosque one of the holiest
sites in Islam Israeli police put the
scanners there after a deadly attack
against them last week they claim was
launched from the mosque Palestinians
see the security measures as part of
creeping Israeli control over the site
which is sacred to Jews also angry
confrontations with Israeli police
lasted for hours with security forces
using stun grenades and tear gas on the
Palestinians Muslim leaders had called
for a Day of Rage on Friday that anger
on both sides could last much longer
Anthony Jane Ferguson in London Thank
You Jane